only on CBS this morning we are proud to
reveal the 2019 National Teacher of the
Year teachers are responsible for
educating more than 50 million students
across the u.s. the program is designed
to reward excellence in teaching the
2016 National Teacher of the Year
Johanna Hayes now represents her
community in Congress now this year's
finalists include Oklahoma's Donna
gradle the District of Columbia as Kelly
Harper and Alaska's Danielle Rhea
and Virginia's Rodney Robinson and so
now the big reveal the 2019 Teacher of
the Year is Rodney Robinson he Rodney
teaches social studies and history at
Virgie Binford Education Center it's a
school inside the Richmond juvenile
detention center in his lessons focus on
helping his students become socially
conscious citizens who make the most out
of their second chance he is so much
more than just a teacher who the fire
people was the most responsible he is a
pillar of our community he is the father
the big brother friend he's all of that
and more to our students principal
Tanisha Ford recruited Rodney Robinson
to join her team at Virgie Binford
Education Center
I read the story I knew that he would be
impactful on day one the organization
was worth 4 million dollars Robinson's
students have been accused of crimes
from light offenses like skipping school
to serious charges like murder so to
encourage them he covered the school
with college banners and motivational
quotes from the kids heroes 30:48
Robinson has become something of a hero
himself they don't have a ton of bright
spots it's no problem as the homecoming
but it's big Rob it called a big Rob
yeah Big Rob his personality is is big
his impact is big so it just stuck over
a decade ago at Armstrong high school
door on battle and Hubert Anderson were
Robinson's students it means lesson
talking especially was towards Jeff
accidents never slack she
knowledge pay for it are you ready sound
it up battle and Anderson are doing
exactly that
inspired by Robinson they've also become
teachers you have a gym in the nation
you know who's making a solid impact
he's genuine he's one of one no one has
a bigger heart than Ronnie Robinson and
here is Rodney Robinson via Grob to join
us here at the table and congratulations
thank you what's it like to know you've
inspired your former students to follow
you into teaching well that's what it's
all about I was always taught to pay it
forward and bring it down to the next
generation from my mother to Virginia
State University those are the things
that I was taught and so I always put
that into my students yeah what lessons
did your mom give you that sort of led
you into teaching well my mom she there
were five of us and then there were
another 25 because she ran in home day
care but she always taught us that every
child deserves the proper amount of love
to get what he or she needs and that was
my first lesson in equity and so I try
to treat my students with whatever they
need to be successful some need more
some need less but I'm gonna be there to
give you what you need that's so nice -
it was a lesson in is that the heart of
good teaching that lesson inequity oh
definitely definitely all kids deserve a
great education but not all every kid is
on the same level so as a teacher you
need to make sure that each kid gets
what he or she needs to achieve at a
high level you said some need more and
some need less yes but what about the
person that says okay because I'm not
causing trouble I'm getting less of your
attention well when you create an
equitable culture in your classroom the
kids buy into it and they understand
that as a matter of fact my kids often
help those that need more to ease my
burden what's a way to ask this big rob
with your big heart without offending
you or your students but I'm wondering
is there a difference between regular
students and regular schools and
students that are being taught because
they're in a juvenile detention facility
they're different kind of kids there's
no difference no doctors are just
teenagers they like cheesy teenage stuff
like I'm teeny
here wolf and Hannah are their favorite
shows but they just made mistakes and
they're painful mistakes but America is
a country and second chances in order
for them to get achieved and get that
second chance they deserve a quality
education like everybody else because
they're in the system do they feel like
that idea of equity is farther away from
them because of what they've experienced
in their life so far
well they've experienced some bad
experiences in the past in school but
when cashews come to my school I let
them know that hey you're number one I'm
gonna give you what you need the school
environment everyone all my coworkers
we're gonna give you what you need to be
successful the best quote we had was one
student said I like this school I wish I
could go here but not be here to go
that's good what is this honor mean for
you to be named Teacher of the Year it's
it's just recognition of my students my
students are so amazing and their story
doesn't get told and so a lot of times
it's just a great opportunity to tell my
students that sometimes a temporary
setback can be what you need in order to
succeed in life what's the part of
teaching and learning that most unlocks
for them how wonderful this can be to
learn new things is it a fact is it a
story
what is it the stories stories and
connections kids make those connections
to those stories to those people who
look like them that's why culturally
relevant teaching is so important and
once you get that connection and give
them that story then they can achieve no
you said you you know you weren't
supposed to tell anybody but you told
your mom you got it why did you tell her
early upset that I cut that a secret but
okay you know that disappointing look
the parents give you so you have this
year to be Teacher of the Year what's
the main issue that you want people to
know the main issue I want people to
know is that we need economic and
cultural equity across the board by
economic by economic equity we need to
make sure all students receive the
resources to achieve what he or she
deserves and we are cultural equity we
need to make sure that all students have
teachers and people who look like them
who rep who are relevant to their
culture and can
by them to do with that I know a teacher
can make a big big big difference should
be our number one priority big Rob we
love you we sing a big heart that's
right my goodness you can see it from
space congratulations we're really glad
to have you here